today's video is brought to you by
Squarespace more on them in just a bit
the founding of the state of Israel in
1948 is one of the 20th Century's most
important events it changed forever the
geopolitical situation in the Middle
East triggered the mass migrations of
millions of people and created numerous
religious cultural and moral questions
that the region and the world have been
struggling with ever since man most
directly responsible for that event
didn't initially look like a
prototypical national icon to feed
ben-gorium was already an old man at the
time of Israel's founding a short
balding figure who possessed little
personal Charisma or Charm earning
himself few friends and great many
enemies what he did have was doggy
determination Decades of experience and
a single-minded focus to establish for
the world's Jews a country of Their Own
no matter what the cost was no matter
who or what had to be sacrificed
Ben-Gurion became Israel's first prime
minister leading the new country through
the harrowing early days of War fighting
off five different armies attacking from
all sides then engaging in the
precarious practice of building a new
nation once peace was achieved these
Israel that resulted was far from
perfect the compromise is required with
the various internal factions we're
never going to make anyone happy and the
decisions made have engendered
controversy ever since but there is no
doubt that Israel today would not be in
the position that it is without its
founding father who was named one of
Time magazine's 100 most influential
people of the 20th century
the man who would become one of the
world's most famous Jews was born David
Gruen in 1886 in the Polish town of
plonsk then under the control of the
Russian Empire during these formative
years grown as a boy would Embark upon
the great love affair that would consume
him for the rest of his life not with a
person but with an idea Zionism was a
movement founded by Theodore Hazel in
1896 concerned with a simple yet
profound idea that the world's Jewish
population which had scattered around
the world over the course of the last
two thousand years would never know
peace and safety unless they returned to
their ancestral Homeland the country
promised to the followers of Moses by
God this country went by many names the
Kingdom of Israel the Holy Land Zion and
his modern name Palestine Zionism called
for Jews to immigrate to Palestine which
at the start of the 20th century was a
province of the Ottoman Empire and to
establish a country of their own there a
Jewish state it was considered a fringe
belief among Jews an impossible fantasy
dreamed up by idealists most Jews prefer
to remain in their traditional homes in
during the discrimination and occasional
violence of their genteel neighbors as
they had always done those who did
choose to emigrate overwhelmingly chose
to go to the new world between 1900 and
1914 almost 2 million Jews passed
through Ellis Island in New York in that
same period only about 35 000 trees came
to Palestine one of these Hardy
volunteers was David groon who arrived
in 1906 with some friends from plantsk
he was not a natural-born farmer instead
taking to political organizing
especially in the labor movement among
the small Jewish population of Palestine
in 1909 he started using the pen name
David bengurion giving himself a Hebrew
surname after a First Century A.D Jewish
Statesman in Jerusalem the name would
stick for the rest of his life despite
expressing interest in becoming an
ottoman citizen he was deported by the
authorities during the first world war
along with thousands of other enemy
aliens and he ended up in America where
he went on a public speaking tour to try
and drum up support for Zionism usually
without much success he enlisted in the
British army as a member of the Jewish
Legion in 1918 but never saw combat
matters the war ended before he could
arrive at the front he returned to
Palestine which was now under the
control of the British bringing his new
wife Paula and their infant daughter
from her home in New York to live with
him it would not be a happy marriage
Paula was entirely devoted to him but he
didn't return the favor throughout the
next two decades ben-gurium steadily
Rose in importance in the Jewish
political sphere in Palestine being
elected Secretary of the historate the
labor union that had over two-thirds of
the Jewish Workforce as members as well
as founding a new political party in
1930 mapai a center-left Zionist labor
party in 1935 he was elected to head the
Jewish agency which made him the de
facto leader of palestine's Jews today's
video is brought to you by Squarespace
the all-in-one platform for building
your Brands and growing your business
online with Squarespace you could stand
out with a beautiful website engage with
your audience and sell anything your
products content you create even your
time look I've been using Squarespace
for a while now and I just love it it
just makes everything easier let me tell
you about some of my favorite features
first up there's member areas this
feature is perfect for creators and
Educators who want to monetize their
content and expertise in a way that fits
with their brand with member areas you
could sell access to gated content like
classes online courses or even
newsletters next up email campaigns most
important to stand out in people's
inboxes these days and Squarespace makes
it easy to do just that with their
built-in analytics as well you can
measure the impact of every email you
send and improve your future emails plus
you can customize email templates to
match your brand which is very nice and
let's not forget the power of analytics
squarespace's in-depth website analytics
tools provide powerful insight into
who's visiting your site how they're
interacting with your content Etc so
look if you're ready to launch your
brand or Business Online head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com biographics to save 10
of your first purchase of a website or a
domain thanks for watching and
Squarespace sponsoring today's video and
now let's get back to it
bengurion's power as a leader did not
come from personal Charisma or from
soaring speeches he was very short
spoken a shrill voice and had no sense
of humor to speak of and seemed to have
trouble relating to people on a personal
level most of the time What attracted
people to Ben-Gurion was his dogged
determination to get what he wanted he
believed it was his sole mission in life
to find a home for the Jews in Palestine
and was willing to pay the price to do
absolutely anything in order to
while other people only talked he took
action which made people around him
admire him but also scared them which
was why he had few close friends
ben-gurion's dreams were running into a
serious problem however in the form of
the British authorities who governed
Palestine who were having a very hard
time on keeping a lid on the province
the central problem was trying to keep
the peace between the increasingly
militant Jewish and Arab factions in the
country who were engaging in acts of
violence both against each other and
against the British the unspoken secret
of Zionism was that in order for the
Jewish state to come into existence
something would have to be done about
palestine's Arab population which
greatly outnumbered the Jews it would
either have to be forced from their
homes or else so many Jewish immigrants
needed to be brought in that they would
form a majority population there seemed
to be little chance of the groups
cooperating with each other so
idealistic Notions of a single country
jointly ruled by Jews and Arabs or
quickly thrown out the outbreak of World
War II only increased tensions between
the British Administration the Jewish
militia the haganah and the several Arab
militia groups that had risen up in
revolt against the British starting in
1936. the British government government
was worried that unless they made
concessions to the Palestinian Arabs
that they would Ally themselves with
Nazi Germany and attempt to achieve
independence so they severely curtailed
the number of Jewish immigrants allowed
into the country stymying Ben-Gurion and
the zionists whose aspirations were tied
to building a Jewish majority in
Palestine by collecting as many Jews as
possible from around the world there as
early as 1942 reports were reaching the
outside world of the wholesale Slaughter
of Europe's Jewish population at the
hands of the Nazis and their allies
known in Hebrew as the shore the
catastrophe the Holocaust owes one of
the worst atrocities in the history of
human Civilization by the time the war
ended an estimated six million Jews have
been murdered a figure representing a
third of the entire world's population
and two-thirds of Europe the worst
affected was bengurion's home country of
Poland where 90 of the Jews died in 1939
Poland had 3.3 million Jews living in it
by 1950 they're only 50 000 left who
hadn't been murdered or fled langurion
whose own niece have died at Auschwitz
viewed the Holocaust as a natural
culmination of centuries of
discrimination and Malice against the
Jews and only reinforced his belief that
unless they had a country of their own
the Jews would continue to face
massacres until none of them were left
preventing a second Holocaust would be
the rallying Cry of Ben-Gurion and the
zionists from now on privately however
Ben-Gurion would face criticism for some
of his remarks about the tragedy
particularly his belief that those who
died were partly to blame because they
hadn't emigrated to Palestine before the
war they would also be controversy about
what if anything the Jewish agency in
Palestine could have done to save more
Jews from the Holocaust it is known that
Ben-Gurion viewed most of the rescue
schemes brought to his attention for
bringing Jews out to the occupied
countries to be a waste of resources
particularly if it involves settling the
refugees anywhere other than Palestine
the cause of Zionism had to come firstly
argued it was just another example of
the ruthlessness that would both ore and
terrify as compatriots in the years
ahead
foreign
by 1947 the British were doing
everything they could to disentangle
themselves from the trouble in Palestine
they referred the issue to the United
Nations who eventually decided on a
petition of Palestine into two countries
one Jewish and one Arab it was the best
of a series of bad options according to
experts at the time because there seemed
to be no peaceful way to proceed that
both sides would agree on it was now all
but certain that the only way to truly
settle the issue would be on the
battlefield violence began in Palestine
almost immediately following the
announcement of the partition plan
Jewish and Arab militias engaged in
guerrilla warfare and acts of terrorism
against each other with countless Tales
of murder and reprisals particularly in
the countryside the hagenar had largely
suppressed Arab resistance in the areas
assigned to the Jewish state in the
partition plan by the spring of 1948 but
this would prove to be but act 1 in the
unfolding drama on May 14 1948 as the
last British troops were preparing to
leave the country David ben-gorian
announced to the world the establishment
of the state of Israel the culmination
of 40 years of work building to this
moment he didn't have time to celebrate
for long though the next day as expected
the armies of palestine's Arab neighbors
invaded the country from all sides the
leaders of trans Jordan Egypt Syria and
Iraq all rejected the U.N partition plan
and were Allied together to crush the
state of Israel in its infancy they
weren't doing it out of compassion for
their Palestinian counterparts though
each of the countries that made up the
Arab League had their own motivations
for getting into the war Egypt and trans
Jordan in particular hoped to Annex
large SWAT Palestine for themselves once
they conquered the territory despite the
fact that both the United States and the
Soviet Union quickly gave official
recognition to Israel not many people
gave the new country much of a chance
against the combined onslaught of five
different armies the haganah which would
form the core of the Israeli Defense
Forces or IDF was small under-equipped
and undertrained in the early stages of
the war Jerusalem was put under siege
while the Arab armies Advanced from the
south and the East pushing the Israelis
back to the Mediterranean Coastline
Ben-Gurion now Israel's prime minister
and his new cabinet needed to work like
a miracle if they were going to survive
the hagenath had been smuggling weapons
into the country for months before the
end of the Mandate funded in large part
by wealthy American Jews the Israelis
were able to get their hands on a large
amount of surplus World War II equipment
while agents went around the world
recruiting Veterans of the conflict to
fight for Israel much of the early
Israeli Air Force consisted of Americans
who had been fighter pilots during the
war and the first Israeli general or
aleph was a New Yorker named Mickey
Marcus who became famous for building
the Jerusalem Burma Road to relieve the
siege of the holy city before being
accidentally killed by friendly fire in
June the idea benefited from the poor
coordination of the Allied Arab armies
and who had overcome the Manpower
imbalance by conscripting every Israeli
citizen between the ages of 17 and 25
into the IDF Universal conscription is
still a Cornerstone of Israeli defense
policy today by the time the war ended
in March 1949 Israel controlled both the
territory designated for the Jewish
State and 60 of the Arab State territory
including the Western half of Jerusalem
and the entirety of the Negev Desert in
the South which would be to prove
crucial and uranium was discovered there
later Jordan would Annex the eastern
half of Jerusalem and the area known as
the West Bank while the Gaza Strip in
the southwest of the country was
controlled by the Egyptians Ben-Gurion
has received mixed reviews for his
leadership during the first arab-israeli
war he's given credit for organizing the
infrastructure of Israel after its
founding including successfully
concentrating the various Jewish
paramilitary groups into the combined
IDF but he had little experience with
military strategy and his near constant
meddling in the day-to-day conduct of
the war infuriated his generals and was
considered to be more of a hindrance
than a help one of his most unpleasant
traits was his eagerness to portray
himself as an expert in subjects that he
was not an expert in Combined coupled
with a tendency to become irritated when
more knowledgeable people contradicted
him many contemporaries believed that he
had an inferiority complex because he
never completed his college education
and was attempting to overcompensate for
this the biggest controversy of the
nascent Israeli government during the
war was the mass Exodus of over 700 000
Palestinian Arabs out at the country by
the time the war ended it is believed
that up to 75 percent of those who fled
were compelled to leave by the Israeli
military as part of an official policy
that went all the way up to the Prime
Minister bengurion himself had always
believed that it was impossible for Jews
and Arabs to coexist peacefully in
Palestine and at times made racist
statements about Arabs in general and
the Palestinians in particular that they
were primitive foreign alien hundreds of
towns and Villages were emptied out
their populations replaced by new Jewish
immigrants even large cities like Jaffa
were decimated the ancient city whose
Origins date back to 1800 BC went from
60 000 Arabs to four thousand over the
course of the war and would eventually
be absorbed into the neighboring city of
Tel Aviv Palestinians who fled as part
of the nakbar the disaster found
themselves in a bad situation most of
them ended up in refugee camps in
neighboring countries where they lived
in squalid conditions nobody wanted to
be responsible for them the Arab states
refused to assimilate them into their
own countries preferring to use them as
a Casas Burleigh for future Wars with
Israel while there's Israelis denied
them the right to return to their former
homes or to compensate them for the loss
of property apply to the Palestinians
continues to be a sore point in the
Middle East this day a troubled Legacy
that Israel has struggled with ever
since nigerian's active participation in
the expulsion is one of the biggest
criticisms of his time in office seen as
yet another example of his willingness
to make ruthless decisions to achieve
the goal of a Jewish State matter what
the cost
foreign
things didn't get any easier for Israel
following the 1949 Armistice
ben-gurion's government now had to forge
an entirely new kind of nation the only
one in the world where the majority of
its citizens were Jewish things could
have very easily slipped into the kind
of chaos that often surrounds the
foundation of new States especially
surrounded by hostile neighbors their
attentions not only between Arabs and
Jews but between the Jews themselves
hostility between Jews who immigrated
from different parts of the world a
constant tug of war between followers of
Orthodox Judaism and secular Jews and
political conflicts between left-wing
and right-wing coalitions the leadership
of David Ben-Gurion is singularly
credited with helping to stabilize the
situation following the war and setting
Israel up for future success his most
prominent achievements include the
establishment of a national education
system that would become one of the
finest in the world striking a balanced
policy between the Orthodox and secular
Jews that rallied both factions behind
him the construction of the National
Water carrier that continues to bring
vital supplies of water from the Sea of
Galilee to the Arid Central and Southern
regions of the country and perhaps most
importantly of all the establishment of
a stable democratic form of government
that includes civilian control over the
military bengurin was also responsible
for ordering the Israeli intelligence
service the Mossad to capture the
notorious Nazi war criminal Adolf
heichmann in Argentina where it had been
living in hiding Eichmann an SS officer
considered to be one of the principal
architects of the Holocaust was
convicted of crimes against humanity in
a widely publicized trial in Jerusalem
in December 1961 and was executed the
following June his shadow would Loom
over the country for decades after he
left government as six future Prime
Ministers served under him in some
capacity he achieved many of his policy
victories through sheer force of will
even when faced with popular oppositions
such as when he made a much criticized
deal with the West German government in
1952 that would see the Germans pay
billions of Deutsche marks to Israel as
a reparations for the Holocaust which
would ultimately pull Israel out of its
post-war economic crisis and helped
build up its industrial infrastructure
capacity
at the age of 67 Ben Gurion professed an
interest in retiring from government
citing ill health and fatigue he
officially stepped out in January 1954
retiring to her communal farming
Community or kibbutz in the Negev Desert
called sederboca his colleagues uh
weren't sure if he was actually serious
about retiring since he seemed bored in
his remote Cottage and he had frequently
threatened to quit in the past it was
just one of his most popular ways of
coercing people into giving him what he
wanted he wasn't out of government for
long following a scandal that forced the
resignation of Defense Minister pin
haslavon his successor as prime minister
convinced him to take up the post
himself in February 1955 and in November
of that year he was re-elected as prime
minister Ben-Gurion would take his
country to war again in 1956 in a secret
alliance with Great Britain and France
to unseat Egyptian president Kamal Abdul
NASA the Suez Crisis ended in
humiliation for the two European
countries and a major image boost for
NASA but Israel did win some concessions
including the reopening of The Straits
of Tehran at the southern end of the
country to Israeli ship and the
establishment of a un peacekeeping Force
along the Egyptian board that helped
prevent hostile incursions by Arab
militants in the later years of his time
in office benger increasingly began to
show signs of his age particularly a
diminished mental capacity that led many
in the cabinet to fear that he was
losing his grip on reality despite
Israel's increasingly strong position
and Military he continued to fear that
his country would be wiped out by the
Hostile Arab Nations that surrounded it
and made a strong push for the
development of nuclear weapons believing
them to be the only guarantor of Israeli
safety this cause to stand off with U.S
President John F Kennedy believed that
allowing Israel to acquire the bomb
would only escalate the situation in the
Middle East in June 1963 after serving
as prime minister for a total of 13
years benger in retired for good he
lived long enough to see Israel achieve
its greatest military victory in the
Six-Day War in 1967 when it decisively
defeated the combined forces of Egypt
Syria and Jordan capturing the West Bank
East Jerusalem the Gaza Strip Sinai
Peninsula and Golden Heights back in
1948 Ben-Gurion had cautioned against
additional territorial Conquest because
of the number of citizens living there
which could potentially destabilize the
country and time would prove him right
while Israel would eventually make peace
with Egypt and a return to the Sinai
Peninsula the other occupied territories
have been a source of friction and
conflict ever since the question of what
to do with them at the heart of the
ongoing dispute between the Israelis and
the Palestinians in November 1973
shortly after celebrating his 87th
birthday bengary and suffered a stroke
he died on December the 1st and after a
state funeral in Jerusalem it was buried
on a Hilltop overlooking stair Boca next
to his wife Paula who had died in 1968.
David bengarant remains widely popular
in Israel and among Jews around the
world to them he's a symbol of The
Rebirth of the Jewish Community after
the depths of the Holocaust and the
central figure in the Fulfillment of the
Zionist dream Homeland for Jews from all
over the world that is today one of the
most economically prosperous countries
in the Middle East but with the passage
of time more and more questions are
being asked about his leadership and his
decision specifically the impact they've
had on citizens of the region in modern
times despite the fact that Israel has
not been seriously threatened with
Annihilation since the Yom Kippur War in
1973 the country continues to maintain a
Siege mentality with regard to its Arab
neighbors both inside and outside its
borders they've been officially at war
with Syria since 1948 and with Lebanon
since 1982 and continuous violent
clashes between israeli's security force
and the Palestinian residents of the
West Bank and Gaza Strip have claimed an
estimated 25 000 lives since 1967. it is
believed the ben-gurion's militant
attitude towards the Palestinian Arabs
and his refusal to allow the refugees to
return to the homes or participate on an
equal basis with the Israeli government
has set the standard for subsequent
government ministers to follow a
particular note is his support for
reprisal operations military actions on
Arab civilian Targets in retribution for
attacks on Israelis which are supposed
to act as a deterrent against future
acts of terrorism and violence it's said
according to many counter-terrorism
experts such indiscriminate violence is
believed to only inflame tensions
further setting the stage for even more
violence on both sides as Martin Luther
King once wrote the Old Law of an eye
for an eye leaves everybody blind
however there is little doubt that for
good or for ill David Ben-Gurion is one
of the most important figures of the
20th century his success is nearly
unparalleled in history a young Polish
immigrant a member of one of the most
consistently persecuted minorities of
all time somehow found a way to lead his
people to the promised land in spite of
seemingly the entire world being against
them defeat the true comparisons to
Moses himself you can argue with his
methods all day long but you can't argue
with the results
is why David Ben-Gurion will be
remembered long after all of us are dead